political correctness is in many ways an
extraordinary and admirable achievement
of our age it involves an acute
sensitivity to the suffering of minority
groups traditionally overlooked by the
dominant forces in society and a
commitment to teasing out examples of
adversity in the large but also the
small moments of daily life its aim is
to spread empathy justice and fairness
for a movement with such admirable aims
it is surprising how many people it
appears to have upset the reason they
lie not so much with its noble
underlying ambitions as with the manner
of their execution when we receive
lessons in political correctness some of
the following may occur we'll be invited
to see ourselves as rather nastier than
we'd ever imagined we might be and much
more closely involved in oppressing
others we can at points feel unbearably
guilty a generous path to redemption
won't necessarily be on offer the
oppression to which we discover we our
party is so large and so widespread it
appears it won't be in anyone's remit to
solve it we'll just need to keep feeling
guilty we realize that the target of our
reeducation isn't just our manners and
what we outwardly say or do it's also
our thoughts our guilt spreads to a new
area the very recesses of our minds we
learn that we are comparatively
extremely privileged what's tricky is
that we may not feel ourselves to be so
but though this is precisely where
informed the leading symptom of our
inbuilt advantages we're so privileged
as to be unaware of our privilege but
inside us it may seem as if we were
being taxed on a legacy we'd never
actually received as if for generations
back we had a wealthy great aren't we
never met and from whom we'd never
received any money but on whose estate
we now learned we were expected to pay
an enormous tax bill we seem to be faced
with an unfortunate choice either we
embrace the goals of kindness as defined
by political correctness but face a high
degree of non redemptive guilt and
humiliation along the way or in a bid to
regain our peace of mind we give up on
all attempts to be sensitive and
generous under the terms profit and feel
ourselves implicitly pushed into the cab
of the boorish the insensitive and
accrued to which we don't actually want
to belong but to which there seemed few
alternatives there is however an
important way out of this dichotomy a
philosophy of social concern and
interaction that flies under a
deceptively simple and traditional name
politeness politeness shares some of the
major objectives of political
correctness it too wants a world of
sensitivity kindness and grace it too
seeks to avoid causing suffering to
strangers but it has some decisive and
very helpful differences
political correctness zeroes in on the
distress of particular groups in society
its selective in its emphasis on where
respect needs to be directed the
ambition of politeness however is far
more expansive if commands that one
should be deeply courteous to everyone
whatever creed color and background they
might be no one is left out and
therefore no one can feel embittered
politeness recognizes we will naturally
and inevitably sometimes have mean or
dark thoughts about other social groups
but the philosophy of politeness doesn't
panic however because it accepts that
our brains are in many ways primitive it
doesn't believe that such thoughts can
ever be entirely removed instead the
effort is concentrated in the one area
where it matters above all how people
actually behave towards one another
day to day this is where politeness
directs all its attention and gets
tricked our manners must be beyond
reproach our thoughts can be left to
themselves
political correctness is highly tied to
politics and specifically to a
left-leaning agenda the big risk is that
if one disagrees with the politics one
might then ignore the overall command
for sensitivity and kindness this is
where politeness has an enormous
advantage for its prior to and larger
than politics
it starts in childhood in the way we
treat our little sister the bus driver
or our Awkward uncle politeness teaches
us tenderness to the vulnerabilities of
others irrespective of what's happening
in the economy and without reference to
a particular interpretation of history
politeness doesn't belong to any one
political group it's simply a basic
requirement of being human
the polite person is polite in a crucial
area the business of teaching politeness
to others they never make anyone feel
guilty for not already being polite they
take it for granted that no one ever
starts off that way they see rudeness as
a consequence of not having been
sufficiently helped or of being in pain
not a sign of evil they make the
attractions of courtesy appealing
through their own gentle behavior
political correctness can seem as if
it's laying down principles we have to
follow politeness suggests it's giving
us aspirations it would be beautiful if
we managed to follow the difference is
key when you have to do something you no
longer feel any pride or virtue in doing
so but if an action is voluntary we come
away with a glowing sense of our own
decency in having chosen the right path
it's the difference between charity and
Taxation the former feels Noble and
kindly the latter and oppressive sure
we'd love to wriggle out of it's a
tragedy of the age that some of the
goals of politeness have been undermined
by the more forbidding aspects of
political correctness we need to
rediscover politeness as a route back to
building more civil less mean-spirited
societies and to giving proper
expression towards always a fundamental
force within us the desire to be kind
and respectful to others did you know
that the school of life is actually a
place ten places in fact campuses all
over the world from Melbourne to London
Taipei to Istanbul with classes and
books and lots more please click on the
link below to explore more